استضافه العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس اليوم
اجتماعا تشاوريا لوزاره الخارجيه العرب
لمناقشه تطورات القضيه الفلسطينيه
ومستجدات الازمه الليبيه واليمنيه
طرابلس باعتبار ليبيا تراس حاليا مجلس
الجامعه العربيه على مستوى الوزراء ويعد
التمهيديا الاجتماع الوزاره العربيه
المقرر عقده في القاهره الشهر المقبل
وقالت وزيره الخارجيه الليبيه ان بعض
الدول تحاول التاثير سلبا على المشهد
السياسي الليبي واضافت في مؤتمر صحفي بعد
الاجتماع التشاوري ان توحيد الملف الليبي
مهم لمستقبل ليبيا والاستقرار
للاسف قد يكون هناك بعض الدول التي ليس
مصلحتها ان ترى الاستقرار في ليبيا اييه
وكما قلت لك بالعمل المشترك
بالتحالف مع الدولنا الشقيقه والصديقه
والجاره والايضا البعيده التي تريد ان
تكون موجوده وتدعم مثل ما حدث اليوم في
هذا الاجتماع الناجح نكسر هذا الحاجز
ونؤكد على اهميه توحيد الملف الليبي لان
هذه مهمه كوزيره خارجيه اريد توحيد الملف
الليبي لكي هذا ينعكس على الاستقرار
الداخلي وعلى مستقبل ليبيا باذن الله
وفي المؤتمر الصحفي ذاته هي قالت وزيره
الخارجيه في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه
نجلاء المنكوش ان ليبيا اصرت على حقها في
ترافس الجامعه وان نحو عشر دول حضرت
الاجتماع مؤكده على الحاجه لدعم الجميع
لضمان استقرار الليبيه
الحمد لله هذا الاجتماع كان ناجح جدا
الحمد لله كانت كل الكلام ايجابي
وهناك يعني جسد
العواصر والدعم للقضيه الليبيه حوالي عشر
دول حضرت اليوم في هذا الاجتماع يعني
تقريبا النصف الدول العربيه
وانا بالنسبه لي اي دوله مهما كان حجمها
او بعدها او قربها همم او مستقره او غير
مستقره وجودها اليوم معنا هو اكبر دليل
على ان احنا عرب نتعارض وفي فرصه للعمل
العربي المشترك
من طرابلس مراسل الجزيره احمد خليفه اذا
احمد ما الذي ناتج عن هذا الاجتماع تشاوري
للوزراء الخارجيه العرب في طرابلس
قبل الحديث عن نتائج هذا الاجتماع عثمان
منذ قليل نشرت وزيره الخارجيه الليبيه
نجلاء المنغوش تغريده
اتهمت فيها بشكل صريح جامعه الدول العربيه
بانها عاجزه عن تحقيق اقل مستويات التضامن
مع ليبيا في ازماتها الحاليه وقالت ان ما
تفعله الجامعه هو همم تحدي همم او ما يحدث
هو همم لا يرقى الى مستوى تحقيق ااه
التطلعات العرب والتحقيق الحلم العربي
وقالت الى نجلاء المنكوش ايضا في
تغريداتها ان حكومتها ماضيه همم لاجل
تحقيق الاستقرار
وشكرت من وصفاتهم الاشقاء الاوفياء العرب
الذين حضروا اليوم اجتماع العاصمه طرابلس
همم على مستوى وزراء خارجيه جامعه الدول
العربيه
وارفق التغريداتها ثلاث صور همم تجمعها مع
وزير الخارجيه التونسي ووزير الخارجيه
الجزائري ووزير الدوله القطري للشؤون
الخارجيه همم لم تعلن نتائج هذا الاجتماع
او لم يكن هناك بيان ختامي فقط استعرضت
نجلاء المنكوش همم الازمه الليبيه في شكل
نقاط في كلمه مطوله بعض الشيء ثم عقدت
مؤتمرا صحفيا تحدثت فيه عن الاجتماع وقالت
ان هذا الاجتماع هو اجتماع همم تشاوري
مفتوح للدول الاعضاء وانه هناك همم عدد من
الدول عزفت عن حضور هذا الاجتماع الناجح
بحسب وصفها
وارجعت عدم حضور بعض الدول الاجتماع بسبب
الاستقتابات السياسيه للدول المتداخله في
الملف همم الليبي ايضا تحدثت همم المنقوش
وقالت همم
ان عدم حضور هذه الدول همم لن يمنح الفرصه
لاجل الاستقرار في الاستقرار في ليبيا
وقالت ان ما حدث يمكن ان ينبا مستقبلا
بحدوث عراقيه للازمه الليبيه التي تنتظر
التسويه وان تكون جامع الدول العربيه جزءا
من هذه التسويه شكرا جزيلا لك احمد خليفه
من طرابلس